Y
VOTING SYS
MILLIONEMENTS ABOUT THE VOTINGND
? I SA DOWN WITHUP OF
EME IS OUR
PU SHOWNDSDBATTLE BETWEEN DOMINE
KNOW THELL
FRAUD. MORE BROADIUSTWASN'T AWAD
FI ESSENTIALLYDEFA. HOWF YOU ARS
$787 MILLIONTL T FOR
PROBABLYE INES. BESTTHEG SYSTEMN
INTERESTBTLE. OBVIOUSLYBOX MADEE
TOOK
ISY, THEY
SHOOTIM AY T FGIT A LOT
THIS IS AAT OF OPINION.
EE FOR THEM TO C TO
BL W
UP THEIR CLAIMS.
REEC IT'S
QUITE FRANKLY, WE'VE HAD OF AMEE
2020 TO FI, UH STUFF. I'MNDERINI
OUT DURINDI HOW
DIFFERENTHEEL
E  T WHAT TWESAYING ON THENSTANC
TH ON SAID BEHIND
TEXT RESPONSE. NOCOULEL WHAT THE
ELL I LOST. LO
TRUST IN THE TTH,
ANYWAY WHEN? EN THE FOXAS
OUT T. I KNOW
A LOTPE WAYALUT THE
, THERE'S BEEN AOTOTH SIDES OF
IS NOT LOOKING TO
BE LIED TO IT'S LOOKING TMETHINE
PERSPECTIV, D  THAT'GOTTA VALUEE
NOT. AND ONCE
HIS NOTRUTHEMNOEN. MOVD ACCEPT U
SPE  UMYOOS,  THEY WENT FORWARDH
IT ANYWAY. ONE. I'M REALLY HAPPY
THAT THAT THEY HAVEGENT
K THEY'RE GOING TO LEARN A YOU I
LESSON. THIS HAS THISNOMILLIONI
LESSON? RYAN? I ME BUT BUT
AT WELL, IESSON IS THAT E IT  BL
ON TRUTH. THER
OF WIL
ARUE O
UE ON THON'T LOOK TO ANYNCLUDIN.
THREE WHO ARE TO BEVOTED? FOX WO
GRAINLT NOW?D
A LENS, NG IT MOREOU? WILL YOU T
SOMETHING YOU KNOW BIG LIKEHAENO
BEN
. WHEN IAT TUCKER
BE WATCHING THROUGH DIFFERENTAIT
E MORE ALIS, YOU MIGHNIEW VSOUME
THAT FO NIS
THE THING CS SHOWING AND
EXPANDING. ET
THITHESEHAVE THESE